Avengers: Endgame​ isn't done giving up
its secrets.
In the wake of the Marvel flick's home release,
fans are beginning to scour every frame for
Easter eggs they may have missed in the theater.
In fact, a big one has recently come to light,
involving a villain who just seems to keep
popping up.
You'll remember that in Endgame's second act,
Steve Rogers and Tony Stark are forced to
use their last Pym Particle to travel back
in time to the 1970's in an attempt to secure
the Space Stone, after their attempt to do
so during their trip to the Battle of New
York goes pear-shaped.
"Do you even know what an Idiom is?"
“Colloquial metaphor.”
“No it isn’t…
well actually yes, but..."
The pair infiltrate the S.H.I.E.L.D. facility
where the Infinity Stone is being housed,
and in the course of the mission, Stark is
thrown for a loop when he runs into his father
Howard.
During their conversation, Howard mentions
Arnim Zola, the HYDRA scientist who was captured
by the agency that would become S.H.I.E.L.D.
during the events of Captain America: The
First Avenger.
Zola was pressed into the service of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
but of course, the nefarious scientist had
a hidden agenda to assist in spreading HYDRA's
influence within the organization.
We subsequently learned in Captain America:
The WInter Soldier that this effort was a
smashing success, and that S.H.I.E.L.D. had
been infiltrated by HYDRA scum to its very
highest levels.
We also learned that Zola, who had long since
died, had digitized his consciousness, uploading
it into a massive bank of old-school computers
as a way of making sure that he would continue
to have influence over S.H.I.E.L.D.'s inner
workings.
“The new HYDRA group.
A Beautiful parasite, inside SHIELD.”
Zola's Winter Soldier appearance concluded
with him destroying the bunker that held his
digital self in a bid to blow up Cap and Natasha,
but in 1970, he still existed as a fleshy
S.H.I.E.L.D. scientist.
However, there's evidence that his plans to
digitize his code within S.H.I.E.L.D.'s mainframe
was already in effect by the time Tony has
his impromptu family reunion.
On a desk in Howard's lab sits an old school
computer terminal, and if you look closely,
you can see that Zola's green, low-res visage
graces its monitor.
The folks at Cinesite pointed out this blink-and-you'll-miss-it
cameo in their behind-the-scenes breakdown
of the Endgame VFX.
Not only is it a brilliant callback to one
of the best films of the MCU, it serves as
a distinct nod to Zola himself.
In the comics, Zola has inhabited a robotic
body since the waning days of World War II,
and he keeps multiple spare bodies on hand
in the event that his primary body is damaged
or destroyed.
Could this be a way for the filmmakers to
leave the door open for his potential return
to the MCU at some point?
After all, who's to say he didn't maintain
a secondary site housing a backup copy of
himself before self-destructing in The Winter
Soldier?
This is a man with a seriously inflated sense
of his own importance, and there's nobody
more loyal to HYDRA and general villainy.
“Once securification process is complete,
HYDRA’s new world order will arise!”
Perhaps this will come into play when Falcon
and the Winter Soldier, the first of the Disney+
limited series set within the MCU, drops late
next year.
Part of the series' focus will be Sam Wilson's
struggle with taking on the mantle of Captain
America, bequeathed to him by Rogers himself
at Endgame's conclusion.
If there's one thing we know about Zola outside
of his unwavering loyalty to HYDRA, it's that
he really hates Captain America, and we doubt
it would matter who's taken up the mantle.
This Easter egg is undoubtedly one of a hundred
or so that will become known now that Endgame
has received its home release.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.